[Applause]
[Music]
unaffordable rents choosing between
meals and heating
and tears when the energy bill arrives
just some of the stories from these
protesters
in london hundreds gathered to call for
action marching to downing street with
messages not just for the prime minister
the chancellor has boasted about
britain's economic record
but the protesters here say that none of
that makes sense to them they accuse him
of operating a scam by offering
households a rebate on energy bills
while hiking up prices
what figures is he looking at he hasn't
got a clue
what kids are they looking at my words
just hasn't gone up or anything like
that so i'm relying on my parents to get
by a couple of days back i got um
a statement from my energy provider
and
to afford to afford it i had to cry
this weather couldn't keep hundreds
protesting in manchester
rising food prices a record cost of
diesel and soaring energy bills
much of the same concerns here what
we're really seeing now is kind of
unprecedented in terms of a perfect
storm of
effects on working people you know
massive inflation getting told that our
energy bills are going up by another 50
they've already gone up last year um
wages have fallen in real terms for over
a decade now since the tories got into
power and we just want to be the start
of a movement against dallas to say
enough is enough
the coordinated demonstrations come a
week after the chancellor said the
economy was back to pre-pandemic levels
that unemployment had fallen and
millions of jobs had been saved he said
business investment is rising and
borrowing is set to fall
out
but hundreds of demonstrators in 20 uk
towns and cities
signal an altogether different picture
sadia chowdhury sky news in london